وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه ما وصفتها
بالاعتداءات الارهابيه والاستفزازيه
المتصاعده التي ترتكبها ميليشيا
المستوطنين المنظمه والمسلحه ضد المواطنين
الفلسطينيين وطلبت بحراك دوليه لاطلاق
مفاوضات سياسيه تتزامن مع الجهد المبذوله
لوقف التصعيد في هذه الاثناء طلب وزير
الامن الداخليه الاسرائيليه ماربين كثير
بتغيير ما سماه مفهوم الامن والانتقال من
الدفاع الى الهجوم واضاف بن كثير في
تغريده على تويتر انه لن يكون هناك احتواء
بل يد ضاربه على حد تعبيره
ومن جانب اخر نقل موقع اكسيوس عن تقرير
للخارجيه الامريكيه قولها ان قوات الامن
الاسرائيليه لا تمنع هجمات المستوطنين ضد
الفلسطينيين واضاف الموقع ان اسرائيل
نادرا ما تعتقل او تتهم المستوطنين الذين
يرتكبون اعمال عنف ضد الفلسطينيين